yeah
how's it going I'm fed you hey shut up
handshake so do you how are you from New
Jersey
from the north all right
good how you doing bubba how was your
day it was good y'all uh yeah
come here I kind of did so like this
girl we walked up and she was like uh
says like oh can we ask you a question
and she's like we're having a private
conversation right now so we've known
and I go oh thank you like talking back
to the same way so I was like that's
[__] so we walk away and then the
girl like walks up all masculine to us
like uh I don't know prove and I was
like yo Lady it's First Amendment relax
you know but yeah all right that's not
too bad that's nothing too crazy well I
guess I have to see the footage yeah
there's another wall that's funny yeah
it'll be good but you guys were there
all day and nobody got kicked off campus
right so I don't know how yeah that's
because fat G was there man I'm the
legal lawyer sir this is public property
is the First Amendment right miracle do
you like Pelosi no did you ever hear
about a guy who took a [__] on her
driveway I did not yeah that was me
yeah I did it on YouTube live
I know it sounds weird it's a little bit
disgusting you know but it is a little a
little but you know you got to speak to
these people back in their own language
you know what I mean like so I used to
stream like against antifa and Portland
and they would like take feces and urine
that would be like made into like a
batch for a long time and they would
throw it at us so I figured that's
that's their language well I do believe
that Nancy Pelosi takes proverbial shits
on the American people all day long but
I don't know that I would have responded
by taking an actual [__] on her driveway
but uh that's why I did it I mean how
did I miss this yeah you know when it
happened right same day after 9 11 14
2020 is the news article in the New York
Post yeah that was after so they had
like called me like a couple days later
for an interview I had every media
Source reach out to me literally
everybody that's crazy that is dude I
got so scared bro I'm like oh my god
what the [__] did I just do bro I was so
nervous because the cop stopped me that
same day was it like an Impulse decision
or was it I was streaming Bro I got I
got baited by you can't really plan that
too much because I mean you can't just
pop one out yeah but uh the viewers like
go to Nancy's house and I'm like yeah
let's go but I didn't really she lived
so close bro it was called
oh I like that a lot yeah that's good I
can't believe the poopalosi guy is
standing in my house yeah okay and I
bought you some meatballs right I mean
just meatballs yeah don't don't [__] oh
no okay all right thank you that's your
dog's job
I think that's fantastic and the thing
that it says they're about you know just
kind of pointing out the the
contradiction between the between their
lives and I so when I was pregnant with
sunny I was living in San Francisco
still I was there for almost five years
and back then there was human excrements
all over the place and now it's
completely out of control and it's gone
so it started out being bad and ugly
there and Pelosi's been in charge the
whole time yeah no problem for her
though living on yeah and it's funny
because this happened like I want to
honestly tell you about like a week and
a half after she had her uh no mask in
their hair salon so it happened like
right after I'm so disappointed that I
missed that and we're realized but this
is way better yeah you met the actual
person you know heard his first hand
okay what else nothing we're just
putting out the stream and stuff are you
guys hungry or not yet I smell fast food
in the kitchen did you bring something
in already or no did we maybe it just
smells like what I cooked it's just me
no it's not people tend to smell like
fast food
that's why guys fat G tells you don't be
a fatty be Natty
get better materials no Natty dude like
natural natural food dude fat ecos
processed natural health foods will keep
you not beautiful we'll give you a
better shot yeah yeah should we eat them
on stream or should we just eat now yeah
let's do uh uh I gotta make macaroni and
stuff so take it so give me a little bit
do a live review yeah a live fat G
review of uh base mother's uh meatballs
oh it's happening
it's happening
yes ma'am
thank you so much guys give a a thank
you to Sonny's mother for the incredible
dinner we're about to Feast on tonight
everybody come over for some reason all
right let's do the live meatball test
don't worry you're good
first
La marinara
you made it by hand yes
way better than Pizza Hut I'll tell you
that I love it
bar thank you no I'm sorry I'm just
joking let's see the meatball dumb
guys check it out where's it how far is
it cam check that out guys look at that
fat cheater pizza that's a fudgy Porsche
baby
um
amazing honestly and I'm telling you
from a fat G
I've been to a lot of restaurants over
my lifetime a lot of Olive Gardens a lot
of Buffets a lot of Olive Gardens no I'm
just joking I know Italians don't like
Olive Garden yeah we were talking about
that earlier how Italians hate Olive
Gardens
no it's actually really good thank you
so much you're welcome I sincerely
appreciate it guys this is actually the
first home-cooked meal I've had like
like two years so
amazing
[Music]